we have a 1200 cubic foot altitude
chamber we have the ability to
manipulate the oxygen level in here to
simulate high altitudes so what we're
gonna do is put you in there and adjust
the oxygen levels to simulate altitude
and have you perform some critical tests
Jeff will wear a 60-pound vest
simulating the same gear he'd be
carrying a amount they'll climb for five
minutes while the science team measures
his oxygen saturation and vital signs
then we'll reveal the enemy but there's
a catch one is armed and the other is
not after intense high-altitude aerobic
activity the Army Ranger will have to
make a split-second decision and shoot
the right guy they will be using
non-lethal cartridges that leave a
water-based coloring so they can see
exactly where the bullets hit first the
fight science team has to suck enough
oxygen out of the chamber to simulate
altitude at 15,000 feet the the concept
of building an altitude enclosure around
a climbing wall has been bounced around
for a while and as far as I know this is
the first time it's ever been done the
oxygen is extracted from the airtight
chamber through these molecular air
separators they suck the air out through
a bank of hoses separate out the oxygen
molecules and pump it back in to
simulate high altitude along the way we
were measuring pulse ox are basically
how much oxygen is saturated in the
blood now normally you're at about 98%
as the altitude increases the oxygen
saturation in the blood decreases a
reading of 95 percent or less could
indicate hypoxia which means the body
isn't getting enough oxygen prolonged
exposure to this environment could lead
to dizziness muscle fatigue and heart
failure with the chambers simulating
15,000 feet were ready for the first
test
all right Jeff are you ready three two
one go
and he seems to be handling it pretty
well body functions all seem pretty
normal just elevated due to the regular
stress of exercise okay go inside weapon
hey hey good come on say Jeff's blood
oxygen saturation dropped down to 89%
this could indicate significant hypoxia
in a normal human being but Jeff is
accustomed to working in this
environment and it has no effect on his
precision
he hits the armed opponents enter body
mass